we are waiting on Stargate because we
are waiting on Amazon to pick a
production company to make the show so
I've had a look at how Amazon have done
this in the past and I've tried to
understand their business model so that
I can explain to you guys why we're
still waiting
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV a
movie channel
[Music]
so I broke the News Guard nine months
ago that Amazon weren't massively
excited by Brad Wright script for
Stargate MGM kept pushing and kept
pushing but Amazon brought down the
hammer and Manson was still waiting for
official news on Stargate I've been
telling you about some of the stuff
that's going on behind the curtain some
of the rumors that have been going
around Hollywood but until we get
something official that's all it is just
rumor now the current state of affairs
apparently is that Amazon is trying to
push to find a new production company to
actually produce the show now why is
this it's the simple fact that Amazon
don't actually make much of their own TV
shows they're a production company they
finance TV shows and movies they don't
actually make them themselves now MGM
have basically been doing the same thing
for a long time due to financial reasons
they sold their Studios year years ago
to Sony and if you actually look at most
of the Productions over the last 10 or
15 years they've always been in
cooperation with another Studio
somebody else makes the show for them
and they just Finance it and then
distribute it but it's all very
confusing when you look at Wikipedia or
other sources and you find out which
production companies are involved in
making a TV show or a movie
the list can be quite long so I've
looked at a few TV shows that Amazon
have produced over the last few years in
the hopes that we might be able to
understand what they're doing with
Stargate so let's look at the boys so
first of all we'll look at Point gray
now that's actually the confidence owned
by Seth Rogen and Seth Rogen even
Goldberg and Eric Kripke are the people
that actually developed this show
originally originally it was supposed to
be a movie but then Amazon took it on
and said look this would be great as a
streaming series and that's why we then
got the boys on Amazon but Point grade
don't actually make the series they
don't own Studios themselves they are
the people that develop the show and
they are involved in the future
development of the project Kickstart
entertainment or another company that's
involved in this now they do own Studios
and in cooperation with original film
who also produced a series
they actually do the production of the
show so they actually have the actors
physically in a studio making the series
now Amazon and Sony pictures are also
involved and listed as production
companies but they actually have not
involved in any way other than to
finance the project
but why
and the simple reason is money
shows like this are incredibly expensive
to produce 10 15 million dollars an
episode is the norm nowadays so you even
have a 10 episode run you're talking
about a potential investment of 150
million dollars now one production
company doesn't necessarily always want
to take all of that risk on board so
they try to spread it out a little bit
in this case Amazon cooperated with Sony
Pictures and they decided to produce and
finance the TV show together now they
half their risk but they also half the
reward now other TV shows for example
like the expanse are sometimes owned
solely by one production company in this
case it's Alcon television Alcon own the
expanse they own the rights
they own the intellectual property
Amazon is a customer that buy the TV
show off Alcon they finance it they pay
our con to produce the show and in
return Alcon sell then the distribution
rights so Amazon owned the distribution
right to that TV show but there are
other production companies involved
again even in a show like the expanse
penguin in a Parker is actually a
production company that's owned by Mark
Fergus now you will know if you're a
regular site tracker that I've told you
the rumors that Mark Fergus and his
long-term working buddy call ghostby
have been employed by Amazon to create a
production Bible for the TV show
Stargate which I've been arguing is in
very early stages of development at the
moment
if that is true this company penguin in
a Parker is one that I thoroughly expect
to see attached to the new Stargate
series when it comes along
and if it is that will be our
confirmation that this rumor about these
two guys doing this development work for
Amazon was true all along the peripheral
is a brand new TV show that's currently
on Amazon if you haven't watched it yet
I strongly suggest you go and look at it
it's based on an old um punk sci-fi
novel it's absolutely fantastic and
beautifully made it's definitely a TV
show that couldn't have been made 10
years ago there are a couple of
production companies involved in this
Jonathan Nolan is the guy behind
Westworld and a few other brilliant
projects like the new Fallout TV series
has been concurrently in development his
production company kilter films is
involved in the creation of peripheral
because Jonathan Nolan is the main show
runner like Stargate used to be made by
gecko films production companies that
were actually created by Joseph milosi
and Brad Wright for example to make
Stargate Atlantis kilter films is the
company that the showrunner works for
and owns and there's 4 involved Warner
Brothers is also involved in the
co-production of the peripheral
um along with obviously Amazon Prime but
it's actually copper heart entertainment
that are actually producing and creating
the content it's copper entertainment
that again rented the studio space and
are actually making the show for all
these other production companies
so this is how Amazon make TV series and
movies they put together a Consortium of
production companies and they're not the
only ones lots of TV companies do this
you can always tell at the start of a
movie if the production company wasn't
necessarily 100 convinced that the
actual result was going to be a
commercial success because there'll be
several production companies it'll be in
association with an association with an
association with they spread the risk
they spread the initial cost and this
way no one production company is too in
stock if the movie then bombs and let's
be honest lots of movies and TV shows do
bomb so there are business reasons why
lots of production companies are
involved there's also though creative
reasons a TV show like Stargate is going
to need significant CGI now back in the
day originally with Stargate they spent
a lot of money actually creating their
own computer-generated imagery but
they actually spent a bloody fortune on
the software to be able to create that
all in-house
but that is not going to be what happens
with a new Stargate series simply
because CGI has become so massively
expensive they're not going to be able
to create a reasonable product by doing
something in-house they will go to a
production company that specializes in
CGI and they will hire them to create
the special effects on their behalf so
that will be one of the companies on the
production list whoever does the special
effects
this show will almost certainly be
financed by MGM and Amazon so you can
expect to see both of those production
companies on the list
you can also then expect to see another
company that will actually have the
studio and that will actually make the
show
you can then potentially then other see
production companies for example penguin
in a Parker that have been involved in
the development
so when we actually finally do get
Stargate the production companies will
not just be MGM in production with
something like Gekko it'll be MGM with
Amazon with penguin and Parker with
somebody else and with probably somebody
else
this is one of the reasons why Amazon is
taking so long to get Stargate onto our
screens because setting all this up and
getting all these agreements takes time
it's also another reason why Brad Wright
isn't involved or at very least not at
the moment because Amazon was never
going to allow MGM to make this TV show
the way they've made Stargate previously
Amazon have a very different business
model and even though we didn't realize
this a few months ago
Stargate was never going to get to our
screens as quickly as we'd hoped but
there is good news on the horizon I'm
told that Amazon really do want a lot of
big announcements in and around this
date of January 15th when MGM plus
launches lots of big news stories to
help push the subscription Channel and
hopefully get lots and lots of
subscribers to MGM plus quickly one of
the ways they can do that is by
announcing Stargate because they know
we'll all go [ __ ] crazy my channel
for example will go mental I will go
live I will probably go live for several
hours because I will be very excited the
video of me announcing the new Stargate
series will have a lot of no no no no I
told you so I'm sorry I'm a very petty
man but also it will just be a glorious
celebration of what we've been so
desperately waiting for for over a
decade
so
fingers crossed we are going to have a
very bright 2023 while we look forward
to a new Stargate series and maybe a
movie or two but guys get in the
comments to tell me what you think about
everything I've been talking about I'd
love to know also if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
and if you enjoy the content don't
forget to become a fully fledged side
tracker and hit the join button as
always please stay safe I'll see you
next time
[Music]